i feel like i'm gonna have like so many
different chapters in my life miley
cyrus wrote a very personal message to
someone she's known over half her life
[Music]
[Applause]
in tribute to the disney channel
phenomenon's 15th anniversary
the 28 year old singer reminisced about
her life as hannah montana
calling her quote the greatest gift a
girl could ask for in this handwritten
letter she posted to twitter on
wednesday
i think just being who i am because if i
had to put on act all the time there
would be no way i could keep that up
every day
miley reflected on her life and career
with the fictional pop star
and revealed the character never felt
like an alter ego to her
she wrote quote there was a time in my
life when you held more of my identity
in your glove it than i did in my bare
hands
stop it really stop
miley added quote you were like a rocket
that flew me to the moon and never
brought me back down
it's hard you know so luckily for me i
um i'm a fan of wigs
and the milestone celebration didn't
stop there
your dad's having a bromance worse he's
having a joe bromance
joe jonas shared this gift from miley or
should i say hannah
to his instagram stories thanking her
for his guest appearance on the series
with the jonas brothers
dudes it's hannah montana
rapper offset touted his present on
instagram a tribute to the migos hit
hannah montana
can't handle them and the card even
reads quote i heart your song about me
15 year anniversary on channel you did
appreciate it
miley ended her message with this
heartfelt sentiment for the beloved
character
saying quote breathing life into you for
those six years was an honor
i am indebted not only to you hannah but
to any and everyone who believed in me
from the beginning
you all have my loyalty and deepest
appreciation until the end
with all sincerity i say thank you
etie followed miley on her rise to fame
where she opened up about the struggles
of being a pop star on screen and off
once you start getting tired and you're
not having fun anymore that's when it
becomes so much like
work that then it's not even like it's
you know you're chasing your dream it's
the reason i'm here the thing that keeps
me going
and that keeps me going fast and it
keeps me going strong is just that
little bit of fire you know that i just
want to like
i do want to keep going